well i don't think there is a single
silver bullet but we do have to
recognize
that uh the vaccine is for the best and
safest route out of this crisis and it's
right
the government is making the investment
and
uh placing these orders with these
vaccines so that we have a range of
options so
we're one of the countries as best place
as we come out of this pandemic
to be able to offer a broad range of
vaccines that are going to protect this
country for the future
how will you decide who gets priority
access well
um the first stage will be obviously uh
sort of
as critical uh those critical workers
and there'll be a
basis of assessment but it's making sure
that we have vaccines
for the whole population that's why the
government has
been investing on such a broad range of
vaccines we're seeing amazing
developments at
oxford university and also imperial
because those people who are leading
vaccine research
recognize it's really important to
effectively spread the range of vaccines
that you're going to be investing in
to ensure that you have the very best
vaccines
uh available to the whole uk population
and
in the uk we have some of the best
research and development anywhere in the
world
but the government's even taking it a
step further and making sure that we
don't just have the best research and
development anywhere in for
every anywhere in the world but we also
have some of the best manufacturing
and you're seeing that in the expansion
of vaccine manufacture up in livingston
and scotland
but also uh in oxfordshire as well
big investments that will prepare us and
protect us for the future
got it um all well and good everybody
has to use it in order or to
be given the vaccine in order for it to
be effective a poll this morning saying
25
of the population may refuse this
vaccine if they do
then the effects will certainly be
negated won't they
well what we've seen is that uh
the british population are very good at
recognizing the importance of
uh vaccines i think that we've both you
and i
will have had the experience of being
vaccinated our children will have been
vaccinated i know my children have with
mmr
and it is contingent on a very high
proportion of the population
uh taking these vaccines in order to be
able
to create the immunity across the whole
of society so
it is a it is a responsibility that uh
i'm sure that the british people will
recognize
because it's for their safety it's for
their good and it's for the good of a
wider society as well
just looking at some figures this
morning um secretary of state saying
that more than 200 000 people
could die from the impact of lockdown
and protecting the
nhs do you think that history
will remember lockdown as the correct
decision
in the fight against covert 19. it was
very much of a right decision
incredibly tough decision to take but
what is important is that we start
getting things back to normal at the
very earliest stage we've
got to start bringing things back
whether that is
seeing all schools returning in
september whether you're seeing
businesses opening up their doors for
the first time again
but all the way through this crisis the
nhs has done a magnificent job
not just in terms of supporting and
helping those people who were suffering
from coronavirus
but also keeping open their doors to
ensure that they look after and support
patients who are suffering from a whole
range
of different issues and that's been
incredibly important but
as we see more and more of society
returning back to normal it's right to
do this in a careful and cautious way
but we do need to get people back want
to come back onto schools but let me
just
finish on that point if i made 200 000
people as i said could die from the
impact of lockdown
that's collateral damage that we're
prepared to accept
there's there's no collateral damage
that anyone is prepared to accept
what we're doing is we're bringing
society back
we're making sure that uh everything is
working and
running as we'd expect and want them to
see and we see that with
schools returning fully in september
we see that in terms of shops and
other sort of non-food retail all being
able to
open and people able to get on with
their lives in a sensible and cautious
way
but we are dealing with a global
pandemic where many many hundreds of
thousands of people
could have died as a result of it and
governments right across the world
had to take difficult decisions but i
believe that
history will judge those who have been
the right decisions
but it's important to get services back
up and running
making sure that services are working
for everyone and making sure
that there aren't uh you know we do
everything we can to minimize the
long-term consequences of this pandemic
another couple of things to talk about
so let's crack on if we may uh talking
about schools you're telling us about
lots more money for schools
uh today is this new money or is this
part of the plan you already announced
in 2019
so it was part of what we announced in
uh last year the prime minister's pledge
to make sure that
every primary school gets a minimum of
four thousand pounds per pupil
every secondary school gets a minimum of
five thousand pounds per pupil
and uh that's something that we're going
to be achieving uh
next year we're going to see every
primary school pupil
bringing 4 000 pounds per per child to
that primary school
for every secondary school it's going to
be a minimum of 5 150 pounds per child
so
over and above what the prime minister
pledged it was a an extra 2.6 billion
pounds for this
financial year and that's going to be
increasing to 4.8
and it's all part of the government's
plan to put more money into schools
and schools back uh in august september
what are you gonna do if parents still
keep their kids off school
well we are making schools compulsory
and i think
you'll appreciate uh how important that
uh
it is for all of our children to get
them back into school like so when you
say i don't know about what happens
i didn't mean to talk across you um i
see what you did there
um but my point is uh what happens if
parents don't send their kids back to
school well
we've made it clear this is compulsory
parents do need to be sending their
children
back to school if ultimately they
continue to ignore the fact that their
children need to be in schools
if they continue to fail to work with
the schools
to get their children back well then
at the most extreme level they could be
liable to a fine
so if parents don't take their kids back
to school
at the start of the autumn term they'll
face a fine well i think you actually
ignored the first bit of the answer to
the question that we'd ask
schools to work very closely uh with
those parents to encourage them and work
with them to make sure their children
are back in schools
fines are only ever used as an absolute
last resort
but you know and i know it's so
important to get children back into
schools
children gain so much for being in
school they benefit from the
inspiration of their teacher at the
front of a classroom they benefit from
everything they are learning but also
being with their friends
and it's absolutely vital not just for
the child but for society as a whole
that we make schooling compulsory it's
the bedrock
of our future and if we do not have
compulsory education
it's something that we'll suffer from
long term in the future and i
i don't know about you but i'm certainly
looking forward to my children being
able to have the opportunity to be back
in school and be able to gain everything
that they
they do from being in school okay my
child's 27 so unlikely
let's talk about china the shadow
foreign secretary lisa nandy uh saying
we should freeze the assets
of chinese nationals involved in the of
the oppression i should say of the uyga
muslims
would you support that well the
government has uh
made it clear in terms of its uh uh
position and the foreign secretary was
very clear in his language uh
yesterday on the andrew marr show
the foreign secretary be making a
statement later today and it'd be
a wrong meet for me to prejudge as to
what he'll say in that
so you don't have a view on the way that
china's well i very much agree with what
the foreign secretary said yesterday
in terms of uh you know the
inappropriate way and the
the gross way that uh china has been
dealing with uh
uyghur muslims and the foreign secretary
be making a statement in the house of
commons and of course you'll appreciate
that's
absolutely the right place to be making
such a statement
yeah but i wonder what we can do as a
nation to take on
uh china you know what what do we have
in our locker that we can
use okay i think you've already seen
that britain has never been
nervous about raising its concerns with
the people's republic of china
about human rights abuses this is
something
that david cameron did when he was prime
minister it was what theresa may did
when she was prime minister and it's
certainly what boris johnson
uh does as uh as prime minister
but we've also seen with hong kong with
what we believe is the infringement of
the basic law
the fact that the government has been
willing to take action
not just in speaking out against this
but also being able to offer
uh british bno holders
um sort of a route to citizenship
here in the united kingdom recognizing
our unique obligations to
the territory of hong kong and that's
certainly something that
that sort of global leadership has led
other nations such as canada and
hong kong and uh australia and other
nations to actually
make similar offers to the people of
hong kong and it's constantly taking
that leadership forward
making it clear that when china acts in
a way that we do not believe
is acceptable that we will speak out
against that but it is about a global
coalition of nations acting together
and we want to work with china and we
always will uh
want to work with china it's an
important player on the world stage
uh but we must always and will always
speak out where we think it's
they're doing things that are wrong
final thought before i let you go
you probably can't see this but i've got
my snood in my hand this morning
my question to you is from friday do i
need to wear this
when i go to prep for a takeaway coffee
and a sandwich
uh i spoke to the health secretary last
week he said i do
then downing street said that i don't
and then
the business secretary alex sharma said
at the end of last week that it depends
what's your understanding well my my
understanding
and i am my understanding is that you
don't
don't have to but uh i think we've all
got our face masks
uh nowadays and uh we are
i think the most responsible thing to do
is if you uh are going into pret
uh don a face mask if you do have one
available
and be responsible and use common sense
at all stages
well the health sector said it's
compulsory he was wrong yeah
my understanding is that going into
pratt that it is
um it is a it is
it is encouraged though it isn't
officially that you
absolutely got to